it might be strange to remember now but
there was a time when the summer box
office wasn't dominated by comic book
movies how far back can you trace the
origins of our current super heroic
movie landscape it just might start in
the year 2000 when x-men changed
everything
looking at the opening sequence of a
film like 1997 s Batman and Robin it's
the hero who's immediately set up as the
main character in this case it's both
Batman and Robin chicks dig the car this
is why Superman works alone everything
about it is cheesy and over-the-top and
then x-men came along and did something
completely different the film opens in a
Nazi concentration camp in 1944 with a
boy who separated from his parents makes
a desperate attempt to reopen the camps
metal gates with the superhuman powers
the boy is a young Erik Lehnsherr who
would go on to become the film's primary
antagonist magneto but we don't see him
as a villain at least not at first
we see him as a child subjected to
unimaginable horror when it is revealed
that the child has grown into the
villain it's as a sympathetic one fast
forward to the present and it's clear
that the trend of creating sympathetic
villainous hasn't gone away x-men played
a huge role in introducing the idea of a
villainous monster you could actually
care about this also blurred the line
between good and evil while Professor X
advocates for peace magneto is convinced
the only outcome is war but ultimately
they both want the same thing for mutant
kind to be raised up from oppression in
his review of the film
Roger Ebert said x-men is at least not a
manic editing frenzy for atrophied
attention spans its restrained and
introspective for a superhero epic in
fact much of x-men's
hour and 44 minute runtime is spent on
character development introducing
audiences to the main players explaining
their special abilities and delving into
their personal struggles against bigotry
and discrimination fight scenes and
action sequences are there but they're
not the main focus of the film so read
my mind I'd rather not come on you
afraid you might like it it might have
something to do with the fact that
director Bryan Singer had never read the
comics as a kid singer told the Los
Angeles Times in 2016 that it wasn't
until he started watching
the animated series later on in life
that he began to form an attachment to
the characters he explained when I
suddenly come across this universe
that's all about misfits and outcasts
who become superheroes it intrigued me I
started to figure a way to tell this
story not just to the fanbase but to a
wider audience the focus of the film
became a social message as opposed to
the big stuff audiences had come to
expect from action blockbusters magneto
wasn't the only x-men character to get
his on-screen introduction via a
relatable human back story in
Mississippi we see 17-year old Murray
accidentally put her boyfriend into a
coma after she kisses him for the first
time regardless of the continuity
between her portrayal in the original
comics and in the 2000 film Murray later
rogue wasn't introduced as a fully
fledged misfit superhero she was our
point of view character a regular person
with not so regular problems Bryan
Singer told the Los Angeles Times that
he treated the characters in x-men with
quote the same seriousness as those in
the usual suspects that legitimacy was
crucial to making a satisfying movie he
explained saying you can't just take a
bunch of characters and throw them
together and stir them up in a soup and
hope that it works from the beginning
x-men worked to set itself apart from
its comic movie predecessors via its
tone and approached the storytelling
Bryan Singer went into the movie from a
standpoint of really wanting it to be a
serious film set in a fantastic world
but he was also keenly aware of how
audiences would feel going into a
so-called comic movie in an interview
with MTV News Hugh Jackman who played
Wolverine throughout the franchise said
that singer was so dedicated to making
x-men stand out as more than just a
comic film that he wouldn't even allow
comic books onto the set thereby
effectively making source material
contraband hey where are all my comic
books oh those dreadful things I gave
those away
Jackman went on to explain he really
wanted to take calm evil characters
seriously a real three-dimensional
characters needed people who don't
understand these comics might think
they're 2-dimensional the three biggest
films of the 2000 summer box office were
headlined by Tom Cruise Russell Crowe
and George Clooney respectively at that
point in time all
three had proven themselves as leading
men x-men stars were a couple of actors
who were in their 60s a pre Gandalf Ian
McKellen and Patrick Stewart then best
known for telling Wesley Crusher to shut
up in Star Trek TNG but shut up Wesley
the two leads were supported by a mostly
unknown cast who had done some TV work
and a teen horror flick here and there
Halle Berry had done some high-profile
movie work but she wouldn't go on to win
her Oscar for monsters ball or become a
box-office force of her own for a couple
more years speaking with mtv news hugh
jackman said he went into the audition
as if it weren't a real one because he
thought Dougray Scott was already going
to play the role of Wolverine I think I
was sent up there just to kind of send a
message back to Mission Impossible to
like you better hurry out because we're
gonna start looking at other paper right
I didn't think it was a real audition
what x-men proved however is that she
didn't need a big star to sell a film to
audiences end game marked a high for
Marvel Studios and for the comic film
genre but chances are it wouldn't exist
had x-men not first paved the way in
1996 Marvel filed for bankruptcy and
sold off the cinematic rights to several
of its properties in an effort to stay
afloat 20th Century Fox picked up the
rights to the x-men and although the
movie was a success at the box office
Marvel wound up with zero to show for it
two years later the same would happen
with Sony spider-man and again Marvel
would walk away with nothing in 2005
after x-men and spider-man had proven
how successful a comic film could be if
done properly Marvel gambled everything
they had to launch their own production
studio with Iron Man assuring in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe three years
later love it or hate it x-men was built
to begin a franchise and it made major
use of a cliffhanger after the film's
storyline was wrapped up it's a common
thing now but back then films didn't
typically rely on such gimmicks the
ending of the film sees Professor X
visits magneto in his plastic cell where
magneto shares his plan to continue his
fight it's obvious this isn't the real
end of the story and that there's a
definitive plan for more and now we
watch comic films and actually expect a
tease for more I'm here to talk to you
about
Avenger initiative by the time x-men
arrived in theaters it had been over a
decade since Tim Burton's first Batman
movie had set the box office on fire in
the time since superhero movies had
hardly been shown to be a guaranteed
path to blockbuster success even
Batman's sequels had turned into a game
of diminishing returns what killed the
dinosaurs 2000s x-men proved two things
the first is that comic book adaptations
didn't have to be campy
it also proved that comic films could be
profitable longtime x-men comics writer
Chris Claremont told polygon in 2019 up
until then everybody had looked on
superhero films as losers then the x-men
rolled in with a 9 figure opening
weekend which nobody saw coming 20 years
later we are in the world of today with
Black Panther pulling in three Oscars
and into the spider-verse getting Best
Animated Film check out one of our
newest videos right here Plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]